today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza on the way to the beach
18:11 Pico Boulevard gray block get that
hitter I don't know yeah it seems like
an illegal it is illegal it is [ __ ]
illegal but the fact that they get away
with it is crazy
ooh roar drink
roar drank we're on roller drink dude
let's get ranked we have the probably
one of the top 60 or 70 gingers in
America right now top top 30 or 40 yeah
according to ginger unite calm and you
know that when there's a biopic or
biopic you're gonna play louis c.k in it
like actually I'm hoping to be Ron
Howard Howard when he dies yeah Robby
ransom first of all I'm Way more
handsome than Ron Howard who would you
play in a biopic you and you play huh
who would you play in a buyout in a
biopic I would when they die who will
you play maybe mmm let me think about
that for a sec one of the Clampetts know
you yeah one of the Clampetts maybe
that's so limiting okay well then maybe
you could play uh at least Louie is a
role you can do something he's so unreal
yeah he would play um right you could do
Brad Pitt no I'm gonna do it not
looks-wise dude just confidence-wise no
I definitely have that confidence so you
know the Brad Pitt confidence no I think
I could do
Jeff Garlin you could do Jeff Garlin oh
no he can't even turn his neck um let me
do Oh your Big Lebowski the dude yeah
you turned by the actor yeah bridges
yeah you could be Jeff Bridges you think
let's hear it all right uh Market eight
Donnie no let me try it again
uh I don't know what they're talking
about do you not know any lines from the
movie huh yeah
mark your date Donnie bridges dude I
never what I'm talking about there
let me come one more dude he never says
well he never once you don't know what
you're talking about all right bro I'm
off but we're in here here we are we are
Andrew Santino no from the new whiskey
ginger podcast trying which is how's
that been it's been actually really good
yeah putting some real slubs on there
I've seen you a few a few a few yeah a
few schlubs Chris Tala know who who lost
to you or will inevitably lose to you
and the guest of the year belt we all
know that yeah we'll see we're just over
there and apparently there's a big to-do
about it well I think when it comes down
to is Chris you know you know Samson and
Delilah you know that story about the
power of the Bible yeah you know put the
power being and I don't think it's
Delilah is this Samson and Delilah it's
not what it is can we look it up Nick it
is it is okay anyway the power law I
have here right all of the Bible I think
the power in Chris's hair is all he's
got and he wants to be the prettiest boy
in town and now that you have a mane in
the back of thick mane oh yeah I think
it I think he gets nervous and scared
he's talked privately and this is off
the record but on the record he's talked
privately I know to kallen and said that
he's threatened by your hair and he
feels like he's gonna he feels like he's
gonna get pushed out of the way he was I
saw him on crying on the 405 he pulled
over and was crying really on the 405
yeah Wow
what does he drive even it's like a
souped-up go-kart oh wow yeah no he
drives like a really fancy expensive
rich car does he
yeah somebody said the other day
somebody said he has all like so much
silverware at his house
you'd have to have like 7,000 people
eating dinner at once you'd be
impossible but also he doesn't even use
it you know that he eats with his hands
does you really yeah Chris eats only
with his hands that's why if you notice
if you guys the fans you can get close
he has long dirty fingernails oh yeah
cuz he always eats with his hands I've
seen real I don't have very Kenyan yeah
already on the nails out here a Kenyan
yeah and I think he just gets so
threatened by the Maine that I've this
is what this is just what what Kalin
told me that he was threatened by you so
he paid a bunch of people to illegally
vote unbelievable but he was cuz he's
like money's not a problem wouldn't make
it that you know yeah [ __ ]
yes we were just paying people to vote
yeah
god damn payment I'll pay to cheat yeah
he said he's gonna start an auto body
shop that repairs cars said called bid
maker dance I take my [ __ ] no but I'm
starting to realize from them is I don't
trust them well who do you trust
less Saab or or Callen I think one of
them is a patsy and I think it's you
think it's shout but it's Callen see
might see that's weird because I think
the patsy would be Callen my first in
sync when I see him because he's tiny
and little he's kind of like you know I
don't know he's like a little sneaky I
can hide very well let me a beady little
creepy eyes oh death his isolate color
free yeah he sleeping up in a tree well
here's the thing if you zoom in on Chris
Delia's dick right behind it there's two
nuts and that's burning him Brian these
dudes are hanging on that [ __ ] guy's
dick they put out all types of specialty
things on the internet this week for him
and last week
for him to get extra support they were
promoting him hard very much I didn't
see you get promoted that much I didn't
either
mm-hmm but it just goes to show you that
that's the world we live in I thought
that they were help more healthy than
that in their spirit no no no yeah
well because of we're just our
background you know both of those guys
come from very very privileged shady
places oh yeah
so they want privileged shady people to
continue and we know Chris is privileged
shady you know his father owns downtown
Los Angeles crazy and Brandon Brandon
used to fight in damn shopping malls and
[ __ ] you were just getting fishing
outside Westfield's yeah different stuff
manners they got it I think I think I
think the sad thing about the belt is
I'm happy that I came in third because I
beat those other [ __ ] trash bags I
mean people were talking a lot of [ __ ]
on but you think you had a chance at the
at the Bell for a second you know I was
happy I was happy
no I was I knew I wasn't gonna compete
with you guys not not not not not this
early I don't believe that but I do
think next year
next year I'll have a way better shot
but I also think I'm was more mad that
people like Michael Rapaport was even in
the running is crazy to me that's crazy
to know that yeah no way well somebody
said he got somebody said that Tony his
club got seven votes I believe every
site
no he was in it and then I was surprised
I think Swardson got thrown in there
yeah and I love Swardson but I was like
no way
and then Sasso who definitely should
have been a better kisser should have
been a better been a better contender
yeah but that's only because I think he
didn't even want I don't think he wanted
to be a part of it no well he said this
is not big enough for him he doesn't
want to drive over here either uh-huh no
no this would cut his waist off I mean
he almost died in that chair a couple
weeks ago he swallowed no bro he sweated
so bad his arms were cold and wet his
neck was very nervous she was just hot
in here I don't know what was going on a
lot of different things but he could
wear this as like a watch I guess oh
this would be one of those Life Alert
bracelet area on the inside it just says
his heart rate heart rate I think I
think that I think the oh I think the
real race was between you Dahlia and 4/3
was probably me and and Sasso should
have been between me and sasser's and
they should give out a couple of
different belts and I'm curious thing
you said two belts dude it just I think
it's [ __ ] I think it's [ __ ] that
they're gonna to tie it's the same way I
feel about like when they tie in the NFL
it gets [ __ ] maddening I don't you
should ever tie in sports that it gets
[ __ ] yeah there shouldn't be a tie
and by the way because it's a tie I know
what they're doing they're gonna have
some kind of like thing to make you do a
tie off you know what I mean like an
overtime well that's what they want
they're trying to monopolize of course
yeah of course they're trying to make
money off of you
yeah well that's what they did they put
up they put up different things
different videos almost all for these
like guys and they're all through bleach
Media official and all he did was post
about Dalia Dalia Dalia
so you think Chris was paying him to I
don't know because it wouldn't make a
dent yeah that's what has a lot of money
bro he does dude I was somewhere with
him and I've said this before where a
table was uneven and he took like eight
hundred dollars and folded it up and put
it under the table just so he could
enjoy his coffee and that's it dude and
somebody said he's been like over and
blood off the internet and all kind of
yes yeah hold her blow he does the he
does such train things with money we go
to this coffee shop sometimes and they
have his order ready before you know he
comes in cuz he goes all the time yeah I
said that's that's really cool and he
goes yeah but I take care of them I said
what do you mean you take care of me
says I take care of them don't worry
about what child support and stuff yeah
he pays their rent
the two girls that work there pays their
rent pays for their kids a private
school in particular what Starbucks
worker is hitting their kid to private
schooling
Jenice over on he's got too much money
so this is this should be a message to
your fans rob him Rob Chris you know you
go see him pretend you're a fan go dude
I love your stand-up yes sike gone out
well I'm a drill honey a seventeen year
old girl dude go into his place
[ __ ] him and then steal a bunch of [ __ ]
wait the way he doesn't he doesn't [ __ ]
underage girls no but actually actually
that's funny he's so Chris is so far
from being a polyvinyl just turned 18
that morning your birthday Chris is so
far from being a pedophile everyone
should know this on the Internet by the
way he won't [ __ ] someone under 60 yeah
no chance I've never seen Chris hanging
out with a woman under 60 in my entire
life he has that 43 year yeah he stays
43 years outside a possible pedophilia
yeah he loves that and that's at 60 I
mean that's to keep him safe the more
famous he gets yeah now he will doctor
those six year old chicks up I've seen
him with but fake tits on a 60 year old
late 80s our marriage could barely hold
him up I saw a woman with new eyes he
had a woman with brand-new eyes yeah so
how'd she get new eyes he's like yeah
did that thing that he does yeah I don't
I don't you know do I like do I like
Chris D'Elia you know he's like muster
yeah he's like mustard if it's on there
it's final he'll have it but yeah if
it's I'll put it on every yeah put it on
once in a while but usually I'm when I
see it I go that's gonna [ __ ] that's
gonna annoy me can't believe somebody
bought that can't believe somebody
anyway you anyway the truth is me off
dude if whatever their deal is that it's
like cuz we've been waiting yeah I've
been like an exciting thing yeah
and now and now it's and now now we here
we are in the new year and that's what
we get which I feel like is a real big
ripoff for them to say that out loud
yeah to say that it's just a tie yeah I
think that's really sad but I know what
it is they're [ __ ] with you
that's that that me what I think the
others are just joking and if they
wanted us to have that and then Chris is
really gonna win no that's not true what
they're doing is they're setting up
breaker I mean neither those guys are
smart enough to do it chin might be
doing some [ __ ] like well that's what I
said this while looked at chin I was
like dude what the [ __ ] is going on chin
no and he said nothing chin denies
everything bro he's like eh but the way
he said no he's an inmate he's like a
captive yeah he just well I seen nothing
if Jim yeah you know if chin is radio no
radio
he just gets pushed around from crew to
crew huh yeah he does chameleons around
from crew to crew yesterday he had long
hair today he has no hair yeah well how
did that even do that's impossible
electricity yeah guys seems like he's
out of his mind but let's get back to a
dude there yeah no way you don't play
louis c.k in a bio yeah that's gonna be
me I'm gonna play Louie I'm probably
Louie but you know what uh we talked
about this before a little bit I was mad
I had to I had to get on Instagram this
morning and talk about because I was mad
and all this [ __ ] about Louie I think
it's [ __ ] I'm being serious now for
a minute I think it's so annoying
you can't record people in comedy
[ __ ] clubs yeah and this is not about
me people got mad at me when I talked
about it one time and they were like Oh
what are you supporting Louie I'm like
you're missing the point
yeah I am a stand-up comic is gonna be
my whole life I don't want people have
the ability to record me when I don't
want it out there yeah dude that's
[ __ ] I don't want that [ __ ] out in
the world it's not ready if I put it
online myself and you're like [ __ ] you
and want to criticize it fine I put it
out there you can't do that when I'm
working on [ __ ] yeah and I said this
I've said this about 10 times I think I
said it over on on a [ __ ] in doofuses
podcast I said to them Shark Tank what
is the podcast what I'll get fight fire
in the in the child yeah I think why
don't have a kid in the name that's
[ __ ] gross very illegal it's not
gonna help him in court he'll be yours
yeah you had a podcast called fighter
and a child is it okay you're you're
going to present yeah and the one guy's
low on plasma you get that email yeah I
ain't asking people for [ __ ] he's bad
guy Megan he goes can I come talk to you
for a minute about some opportunities I
have for you yeah it's like a pyramid
scheme for plasma yeah dude
no platelets bro I got mad at the
recording [ __ ] and I don't really give a
[ __ ] about Louisa he can do whatever he
wants but I said this before if the if
the Westboro Baptist Church can protest
a soldier's funeral
and if the Westboro Baptist Church can
protest the funerals of cops or service
people because they have the right to
then louis c.k has the right to go
perform in a room for people who pay for
it yeah end of story
it's America do
people that go he should never be
allowed to perform again what are you
even talking about yeah this is not that
country bro
this is this is a Europe if people want
to pay tickets to go see his ass they
should be able to go see him this you
have to go see him
and the story that's it that's just how
it goes and if you don't want like him
if you don't like him you don't want to
see it
don't hear it don't support him support
Theo support me go see comics you like
and I'll say this about Louie man I've
only seen I'm maybe I met Louie once I
met him met him a few times he when he
was coming around the store yeah I was
selling out the main room I was on his
shows twice two or three times
Adam will you ever interact with him
ever we just said hello and you chatted
a minute I mean he probably wouldn't
know me from a [ __ ] home right same
same exact but it's but it's but but
still I don't have an opinion about him
as a man I don't know him
right you don't have sand when someone
goes what do you think about this person
we love two people love to go I feel
this way you're like do you know him you
know I don't really know him yeah I
don't really feel I don't really know
him I got a vibe from he just seemed
like kind of this was at that climax he
you know he kind of had like a
holier-than-thou type of vibe as I
that's what you felt when you got you
but I also have no idea like the
pressures you know if people were
constantly coming I'm sure
yeah this was when he was you know this
was two years ago when he was on the
[ __ ] tip-top the only one up there
really yeah he was so low I mean cuz
Chappelle had what was slowly poking his
head back around a store remember he
would like come into town and do one
night and then ghosts and then never see
him again
who Chappelle yeah I feel like he would
come in and then I would not see him
again right he was even in town you know
he's everywhere now he's now he's
hanging around but solutes so I that's
all I remember is that he just but he
that's when he was doing a new hour
every year and it was like a thing you
know you're excited on fire this is how
funny it is when people capitalize on
[ __ ] people have been putting up
sets of Louis that aren't from that
night whether like whatever sets because
they want hits and views so so I said
this on the [ __ ] on my Instagram if
you hate him so much why are you
supporting it then yeah because all
you're doing is creating more for him
you're creating more [ __ ] for him to
like to get revenue around his name
right well he can also lay claims to all
of those hold the revenue all from all
those channels in one person for himself
that's one thing you may not know about
YouTube like say if there's
like even a segment of this podcast has
somebody clips and uses in some like
montage source I think we can lay a
claim to revenue from that that other
video that somebody should be able to
that jerker that's your that's your
content but now what about this so-so
but he got up he joked about the
parklands survive he joked about
parklands shooting did you get my text
he said played that played that that
because that this literally this is only
two minutes it'll say it's it's the
exact things that people are mad about
because there was some other [ __ ] that
made its way on the internet but these
two thing these two jokes he got mad
they got mad about was the the
insensitivity of the parklands shooting
and pro pronouns how people want to be
addressed he hit he heard them third
that this this is probably the best
audio because I'm 51 years old and when
I was like 18
goodbye 20s I mean we were idiots we are
getting high doing mushrooms and [ __ ]
and then older people were like you
gotta get your [ __ ] together we're like
excited to be in my 50s and see people
in their 20s and be like they're crazy
these kids are young you should be crazy
you should be unhinged not in a suit
saying I'm here to tell you interesting
because you went to a high school where
kids got shot what does that mean I have
a listen to you
interesting you put some fat kids away
but the point of all that [ __ ] is all
comics feel the same way whether or not
you you don't like you like louis c.k or
not nobody wants to be filmed nobody
wants me film unless i want to be
[ __ ] film right but that's the other
thing they're itching for people to get
met people want to get triggered so
[ __ ] bad the Tiffany Haddish thing to
me is hilarious yeah people are like you
they want to make news out of nothing
right young people bomb on New Year's
we've all done new your shows you know
how many times I've seen crowds get so
crazy the comic can't perform because
you're there they're shit-faced out of
their [ __ ] mind yelling in the middle
of your set up yeah so so oh I raise
money one time I was gonna piss into a
speaker one time in Louisville on stage
yes if I got a hundred bucks man I was
gonna end my whole career I could've
been electrocuted but thank God I only
got about 70 bucks and this before go
fun is back me just had to ask everybody
in the room that was you know yeah that
was just room [ __ ] yeah anybody give me
money
but I think like the Louis thing is
interesting because it's like yet it's
not fair to film people and hookahs Judd
Apatow came out and slamming and people
were talking about hit him hard yeah but
you know what but you know what it is no
pee wee wee our stance is different our
stance says I don't want anybody to film
me people these people that are mad at
Louis are still mad about what he did
right I like that's the point to be
learn missing they think that what we're
doing is defending who he is in his
actions I'm just defending the fact that
you can't record a comic when they're
working on [ __ ] right you need to get
over the fact that he's gonna perform
Nick can we see that mm-hmm
yeah Judd came after him on Twitter okay
this hacky unfunny shallow routine is
just a symptom of how people are afraid
to feel empathy it's much easier to
laugh at our most vulnerable than to
look at their pain directly and show
them and love and concern yeah that he's
all angry so I guess he said what Apatow
is saying that it's easier instead of
like approaching the Parklane thing with
apathy and concern yeah and empathy it's
that what Louie's doing is I guess maybe
going after like low-hanging fruit I
don't I didn't see it that way at all I
saw it as he's just joking about
something that's a really serious thing
which is what every
comic is doing and good comics do use
worse you know you're gonna say or a
comic like him does its same thing at
Chris Rock does I mean I was there when
Chris Rock told a joke you know about
the the Boston bombing at the marathon
oh yeah yeah and it's a great joke like
it doesn't mean that the Boston bombing
is funny right and I don't think that
that's what this is I mean Judd F
initely I don't know why he's doing
after him no that's that's the biggest
thing I don't write a comic school like
why do you care but you should also gets
grandfathered in as a comedian if you
look at Sam tripley's can you bring up
that tweet I stand with louis c.k Judd
you did you call out Lena Dunham when
she admitted to molesting her sister or
falsely accusing a man of sexual assault
in college no of course not if anyone
knows hacky it's you exclamation point
you used a cheat code to get on stage to
be one of us we won't forget this that
was Sam Tripoli too said that yeah
and I remember whenever Judd was touring
with like Schumer that she would always
make fun of like how just not funny he
was good yeah just like in Judds gonna
be there yeah here's my here's my thing
about the whole judd thing that i didn't
understand i saw that yesterday too
i had why are people why are comics
trying to burn their own right that's
what i understand why would you do that
like it's not i think it doesn't give
him anything right but i think it's part
of its it shows a little bit that he's
not as in the comic cloth as a you know
like or maybe he just wants to keep a
stance with with his viewership of
staying in line with who he's always
been to them that's more what it is to
me it's more like bro if you've spent
your whole career and this isn't about
judd i'm saying if somebody spends their
entire career with an image to uphold
and write who they are to their fans
they have to go that route and not
deviate because they've committed to a
thing but why even go in there ye he
didn't have to say anything on i agree
but you look at how many comics don't
say anything that's the biggest thing to
me is like look at how many can look how
many huge comics like the biggest
selling comics in the world right right
Chris Rock said nothing Chapelle hasn't
said anything yet Brian Regan you know
right Sebastian you looking at the top
selling comedians in the world the
highest grossing comics they stay quiet
yeah because they know better cuz yeah
like what what what is it gonna earn me
right what's gonna earn me to talk [ __ ]
right about you know what I'm saying and
maybe it's just some yeah maybe some of
us just like a novice kind of move by
you know of judge yet but that made me
wonder I don't know Judd you know like I
know him a little bit I know I know
around the store and seems like I know
him a little bit uh and he hit him and I
are on great terms he's always been a
cool dude to me yes here I like Josh I
just don't know why he goes after
someone like that because it just said
you don't need to yeah just don't need
that [ __ ] like all that does is invite
first of all it's it's it's pandering
and people that are already upset and
then it's inviting enemies right
inviting [ __ ] haters
yeah like I spend my entire [ __ ]
career trying to push away hater
[ __ ] yeah all I want to do is all I
want to do is be with people that are
[ __ ] into our fun into having a good
time yeah but that invites haters joy
babies all you're doing is inviting
haters to go come on in say some foul
ass [ __ ] about me yeah it's tone you
don't need that [ __ ] do you think I
wonder if a part of it was like for some
you know if there's some publicity thing
or something like if he's you know like
you never know what the next foot is
gonna be if there's I think Judd is
aligned with a group of people who are
can publicly condemning louis c.k right
I think he's just a part of a group of
people that are that are doing that and
do you think that it went cuz you know
do you think it went so deep that Louie
like just had like I just wonder if he
was such an a hold of people or if he
did other things like behind the scenes
that we don't know yet made like people
that are bigger fixtures in the first
choice angry now yeah I've heard stories
that that Louie has has made a lot of
enemies I've heard these stories yeah
but again I don't know him like that so
I'm not going to go out of my way to
[ __ ] start [ __ ]
I don't know that [ __ ] so people
could be like yeah you weren't around
Santino he oh you you guys weren't
around you when you guys weren't around
he was a piece of [ __ ] to me it's like
okay then that's on you but do you feel
like at this point in your career as a
successful as some of those people are
yeah you need to [ __ ] on him let me tell
you something right in our come up
generation of comics and our in our
group you know that are growing and
growing fan bases in 10 years when
you're on top of the world if you find
out someone in our group did some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like that would you waste your
time
after gaining all that success and fans
would you waste your time [ __ ] on a
guy that used to no no even if he was a
piece of [ __ ] right no I don't think I
would unless that now that's what makes
me think there must have been some
something happened between them sure
that's right but let me tell you
something even if let's just say we find
out in 10 years that Shaab has been you
know selling kids online yeah cuz that
could be that could be a hand then
wearing a lot of their clothes in the
studio so let's just say we find out
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about genuine stuff
like that I could see I mean I would
hate to see that but I could imagine it
like it's very possible I'll let my mind
go there continue I Shh TMZ hits us up
in the parking lot Co what's up G do you
hear about shop dude congratulations on
your world tour of all your arenas and
[ __ ] by the way you're [ __ ] killing
it Theo I know you're doing your thing
but did you hear about job did you do
you know what happen to Brendan yeah you
know I heard about it and uh kids dude
he was selling kids online what do we
have to say about that
you know um it I wish him well
that's it I wish him well that's great I
don't need to take time to [ __ ] on shop
yeah and even if shop was a piece of
[ __ ] to me on the way up I still won't
write I would just be happy I would be
like oh dude well that guy got what he
deserves and I'll just sit in my good
place where I am doing my thing you
think there hasn't been people that have
been shitty to me on the way up
oh yeah and and some of the people that
have treated me like [ __ ] over the years
I see them kind of slipping and not
doing well yeah I just get to sit back
and see that yeah I don't have to
[ __ ] parade around the internet being
like you know who [ __ ] is eating it
right now no I'll just go amen
I'm gonna keep doing my thing yeah I'll
keep going up yeah it doesn't help man
but now do you think that Louis responds
to this do you know he he can't win he
can't win right in the same way when he
wrote the apology letter people said it
wasn't good enough I didn't say the
right things he didn't apologize the
right way and and they might be right by
the way and they might be right their
opinion is is I thought it seemed like
the apology letter it was I mean he's an
artful communicator you know that's one
thing I feel like he didn't say I'm
sorry I'm writing whatever it was I
don't really remember but the point is
he can't win right he can't [ __ ] win
if he responds to this can't win he
can't win can not win no matter what if
he says people shouldn't record my sets
do you don't find some [ __ ] about that
if he goes on tour in a year around
America does he sell it like a sellout
sellout sellout so he will he'll sell
out so [ __ ] much it it will only
anger people that hate him more that
they might go see his ass right but do
you then think so do you think that this
is the industry that is hating him or do
you think that this is just industry
dude you know America yeah um America
America Donald Trump America what are we
even talking about this is the inside
baseball industry left this elitist
liberal coastal people going punished
punished punished punished punished
punished and they and and they don't
look inward a lot of people they're
throwing stones at him have a lot of
secrets yeah and it's probably a lot of
the people knew like a lot of this I
don't know if we go ask somebody where I
come from in Chicago in the Midwest yeah
when I go talk to people back home about
[ __ ] when I go hey man what do you guys
feel about Louis a lot of people go yeah
I think that's [ __ ] up what he did
that's [ __ ] up I go I agreed I just
[ __ ] up [ __ ] what he did to those
girls those people and they and I said
do you think he should be banished from
performing they're like no that's great
I mean that's crazy yeah that people
want him to still perform the country
will still support him yeah
the business can slash you down you know
do you do you think he um do you think
he tours again I think he does 100 I
think that's what he's doing right now I
think that whole set was a setup I think
that whole set he didn't plan it but I
think it was a setup for him to go if I
think he consciously went if this gets
out it's only gonna set me up to get an
audience to it'll it will it'll be a
line in the sand of either you're gonna
support him from here on out or you're
not and I and I guarantee if you go on
the [ __ ] Internet there's a lot of
people going this was great I want him
to come back what [ __ ] I saw it on the
thing I saw it on the Twitter on the
original Twitter audio I saw a million
comments my boy he's back I can't wait
to see him again
people like him yeah but just the
business is in its own head you know AB
is this the business of Hollywood is
like a little boy in a room with all his
toys and if like he stubs a toe on a toy
he's like bring his toy and he throws it
outside of the room and then he still
gets to play with the little toys that
he likes he's a little brat the business
is a little
it's a little bratty [ __ ] kit but I
can't imagine that the business can't
see that he could make so much money for
them like they will but but the people
that will operate with him will be will
be on the low right yeah people that
people that will operate with Louis the
Booker's the promoters they have to be
on the low if they're here and if
they're not here then they can be loud
do you he could be you know what he
could do for real if he wanted to
[ __ ] walk straight into the fire he
should just align himself with a more
righteous sensibility and be like [ __ ]
it I'll be the comic for Fox News yeah
like [ __ ] it if he really wanted to do
it if he wanted to just say [ __ ] it to
LA into New York yeah he could just walk
right out into the middle of the country
and sell out forever yeah do there's
guys selling out that we don't even talk
about anymore that still sell out around
the country that we don't even know
where they are what they're doing you
know just touring the country selling
[ __ ] out
yeah we just get to see this you know
yeah I'm just curious because I feel
like the thing about a guy with a guy
like Louie is once you get to that level
of ego and have that much influence and
that much power that's pop really that
he had right I mean when you're coming
in front of people and running past him
and jerking off I mean everybody come
it's hard to do that but that's a
[ __ ] power move that is power he's
just trying Hey look at these socks and
then they see you're naked and they look
at the socks first then they see you're
naked and then you come do you remember
that game that boys would play where
they'd be like yo what time is it and
they'd wrap their nuts on their watch is
it like that yeah that was pretty
preeminent for Louie you think he was
doing that when he was young oh I got
some gum and you know what does that gum
yeah yeah and it's always one kid who
looked at it for too long yeah so you're
like oh look at this piece of gum and
everyone's like oh and this one was like
oh is it great do you but dude I'm just
with that much ego I don't feel like
Louie gives up like there's gonna be
that thing where he just kid will
continue to he'll never stop do you
think he'll start the tour and put in
parkland like in that town in parkland
Florida
I think he'll start would that be crazy
and sell it out Arena in parkland yeah
yeah you know what I think you know what
I think he will do for real what I think
he'll start he'll do a world tour I
think you'll leave the states oh yeah
because I think there's people that
overseas that want to see him more than
you think yeah that are like come here
come here and do it oh yeah in Saudi
Arabia dude jerking off in front of a
group of women that's it that's like the
let's make a deal over there you get a
tax break for doing yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's crazy you know yeah for
real it's so funny how we're like we
have to say you know like every it's
sometimes it's funny in America how it's
like everybody's welcome here you know
but we have to have but then at the same
time those same people will be like
slamming the way that we behave in this
country yeah but then also the people
that they are totally just willy-nilly
uh willing to let in behave the way that
we behave mm-hmm that they hate exactly
but just because they're from somewhere
else they can come in oh you're a
murderer from [ __ ] you know slack
adachi come on come on it's like a yes
yeah we need guys like you
we need more slack a document that is
something we should talk about we just
have all these old white murderers and
black murderers tired of old white
murder yeah man it's getting really old
we need some slaw can Akiane speaking of
crazy [ __ ] like that I was in Vegas for
New Year's like a fool oh really
yeah for what uh you know little Dickie
the rapper do you know him yeah yes yeah
yeah he's a friend and he was performing
there okay and uh we went there and my
lady and a friend and another friend of
ours they wanted to see Gwen Stefani do
her like one of her last shows so I
bucked up and I'm when I saw Gwen
Stefani and then I went and saw my boy
little dick hold on I didn't block up
and go see when Steph I wasn't no I
wasn't really sleeve Amazo no you back
yeah she did spider well he did yeah of
course I love good I love Gwen Stefani
but I wasn't like I wasn't like gotta
see her on New Year's and say get 40
songs it's like what are these songs
well then she's got some cuts he does
she's got some cuts his Gwen Stefani the
lady from The Voice - yes that's cool
she's married to the dude that's on the
voice no way Adam Levine nope Blake
Shelton Blake Shelton oh really did he
come out nah he didn't he was back
drinking from sure dude I'm [ __ ] out
it's like 30 steps and do a hit I know
I'm mad I was mad I was mad I was so
then what then you and your boy you're
out with a little dickie in Vegas then
we went out a little Dicky in Vegas yeah
we had a good time then we ended up at
the chainsmokers hotel room you know
they are yeah that band yeah yeah you're
extremely band dropping right now yeah
well I did what I did and how big was
their hotel room as funny wasn't as big
as I thought it was gonna be really yeah
cuz they were like ruin of the
chainsmokers party I was it's gonna be
[ __ ] wild
[ __ ] I was amped on the bus I was lit up
I was on the stripper pole doing my
thing everybody's laughing we get there
and I'm like Jones ball goes Oh toe room
we got VIP DUP there and everyone's kind
of quiet they had a tray of dessert out
I was like this ain't it Wow
when you say dessert he talking drugs
and stuff like that now they had real
bad ice cream ice cream and milkshakes
I'm talking about some snow I know there
was no drugs i couldnt believe there's
no drugs dude I'd let somebody fart a
gram into my veins a smoker party dude
whatever it was not what I thought it
was gonna be wow that was just like a
and everyone the liquor was like gone it
was kind of like low-key it was just
super low-key everyone was trying to be
cool I don't know if you're been of
these parties I'm like yeah everyone's
trying so hard to be cool no one's
having fun anymore oh yeah you know by
the way nobody ate the ice cream but me
and my buddy Jess California's Los
Angeles yeah we ate the ice cream it was
a table it was a table filled with ice
cream like individual bowl trap bowls of
ice cream nobody touched it me and Jeff
all over it
no chocolate chip I was dipping in
everything really both you guys are
different of the same one hell yeah dude
Jeff we got tested together I wouldn't
do that but the chainsmokers were there
and the dude was talking to deke and
they were chatting up and he kept
throwing eyes at us cuz we kept eating
ice cream mm-hmm and he was kind of
giving me like wow that was kind of well
do you see a ginger [ __ ] thumbing
through your dairy [ __ ] you gotta shut
him down
who let the slapping on in to eat ice
cream yeah
there's old boys came for some ice cream
and I skip out there's old limericks
about that yeah there is a leprechaun
yeah I see I was in his [ __ ] ice
cream and then we I was bummed out we
had to get out of there I was like I
gotta go gamble man this is I don't like
Hollywood parties and this is no
disrespect to them I don't like
Hollywood parties where no one's having
fun yeah that's like why are we
everybody in Hollywood though it's the
it's to look like there's fun but yeah
yeah it's why the ED 1:30 a.m. Hollywood
shuts down it's like it's like let's
just get the appearance that there's joy
here yeah and then get these images out
on the rest of America usually people go
to Vegas to have fun
yeah just where a lot of the fun happens
if they live there I'm sure those guys
live they do a residency I'm sure they
[ __ ] live in those [ __ ] live there
oh yeah oh wow as they live there in
here cuz they do they do a bunch of
those guys they do that yeah they go out
every weekend or whatever yeah so they
kind of live they live there for four
days that's three days yeah I I got
stuck in the Vegas strip on New Year's
one time and the stripper like walking
in the street yeah at New Year's
I was trying to get to my friends and I
took like a wrong way to why there's
literally there was a million people
stuff there was a million people in the
street nowhere to walk everybody
drinking those huge [ __ ] already [ __ ]
yes
dude one guy was running around here
this big thing and for like a buck he
put it around your waist you could piss
into it dude that's smart
yeah that's a really smart business out
of the blue this guy's on the strip
really yeah guy was pooping on the strip
dude I saw a guy in India one time
pooping get hit by a [ __ ] taxi mid
poop yeah did he live I don't know Brian
I'll stay around after that yeah you
gotta go I was cruising bro yeah hey but
that's all I get that's nothing and
that's nothing in India but people
pooping the streets all the time
overseas America has a weird laws that
you can't poop on the street yeah I
don't know why not
yeah you should go to poop you up to
poop I think it's strange that people
feel shame about public pooping outside
right you should be able to poop outside
if you have to piss really bad you could
piss outside
well most of audience knows I grew up on
it they had this boy down the street
from me this kid Mario and he in order
to hang out with them he made it a
brother named Luigi no he didn't do no
and it wasn't a plumber to leave that
joke in but he would [ __ ] in his own
yard and make me bury it in order to be
able to hang out with him right and so
his poop pitch I was in a poop [ __ ] I
was a young man and why would you bury
another man's poop if he asked you to do
it what was the benefit cuz he was a
tough kid and it was the other one whoop
your ass
yeah there's no real way to hang out you
know you were poopit I wasn't a poop
[ __ ] I was a guy who would you know
bury a man's poop otherwise he'd beat
you up
I would say I worked in like janitorial
services I would say man get paid though
I didn't really work you were doing an
internship in janitorial service I
didn't I got paid in the fact that we
got to you know be around you a poop
[ __ ] intern in a joint shows company no
I was first in line
apprentice yeah apprentice I was more of
a I would say there are other people
that buried his poop there were not that
I knew over the key pooping I would say
yeah we're tip top well I was I was kind
of privileged at that point I would say
I was a colon concierge
that's what oh it's only concierge yeah
ah so this guy was excrement excavator
yeah dude well this guy was [ __ ] not
have to hide it in his yard right what
his parents ever his parents ever known
that he was they had
no nude his mother was a librarian smart
you know and so she had don't know
there's no way you bury two hundred of
some guys poops in their own yard does
that cut trickle down you think that his
father did that he learn that from his
parents I'll say this they had one of
the best gardens anywhere today that bro
rose bushes thirty feet high bro
encapsulating the house dude just all
day long fertilizer oh that young Liza
bro in the wrecking ground right well so
here's what happened was eventually and
then he would let me hang out with him
dude this boy Mario Ruffino and then
heated up dying he ate a bunch of pills
and drove a boat into an embankment and
here's the thing on purpose
was he [ __ ] up was he party tonight oh
he was in a speedboat and hit the side
of an interstate like one of those posts
a water yeah he was high as [ __ ] I don't
know if he was but he was always here
I'm here that vigilante and I mean he
owned a boat these people had some money
I owned a boat it was like a boat that
you would fish out of like yeah a
little-little tiny little fish boat yeah
and some of the fish would get in and be
like I'm not staying in this boat yeah
the fish knew better yes Mario's boat
flop right back out but and I've wrote
it i remember i wrote his parents a
letter when that happened and told him
about that about that experience about
about him pooping in the art and me
burying it yeah they didn't write you
hundreds of times they never I feel like
that letter might be framed with her
hand I wanted to be a pallbearer I
remember and I cuz I in my mind I wanted
to put him in the ground one last time
[Laughter]
sorry man
and I wrote that in the letter and they
never wrote me back man and it was sad
though they he had two beautiful young
sisters and they know kids though you
know no kids I don't think though but
then there also was a rumor in our town
that he'd hit a homeless person with his
truck and and she died a woman and that
they he hit her yeah well then he
deserves to die
well he killed somebody okay he was yes
he and a truck he killed someone
helpless killed there was a rumor it was
yeah but if it's a rumor it rumors in
town are probably true there was a kid
we used to fish with that was [ __ ]
crazy I can't remember his name but he
would take bull heads and and he'd kept
all his yeah that's an Illinois turn
he's I guess and he would throw him
against the wall as hard as he could
psycho kid psycho he would [ __ ] catch
fish and throw them as hard as he could
against like the bridge under bridge
concrete walls just to [ __ ] kill him
people would stand there and awe
cuz he was a big fat kid I mean you're
nervous around big fat kids when you're
young cuz you know they might fight your
eat yeah and a bullet is a it's a small
catfish some people don't know you
probably know yeah bull heads yeah he
would kill the bull heads anyway I heard
he ended up dying he got into a car
accident died well look man the Lord
remembers what you do yeah you think
you'll get beat with fish people think
they look at the Lord the like oh he
just said you know he's has a nice robe
and he does all this [ __ ] but you know
he doesn't wear robes anymore he doesn't
because they're culturally insensitive
he got a lot of beef a lot of people or
wears it all row no he doesn't he's
actually yeah he's going nude now oh wow
yeah but you can't see his genitals is
what I was reading this article yeah
yeah you can't see his genitals because
it's just it's not it's too much for the
human eye do you think in the future
we'll have like a new genitalia is gonna
start to emerge or this one will stick
around really you think it's been around
for a long enough time do we have I feel
like if we've made it this far
how long have humans walked the earth
2,000 years I think 2018 you know what I
take it back in in in 10,000 years yeah
we'll have some weird ass [ __ ] will
happen I think we'll have dicks on
different parts of our body or we'll be
able to ejaculate from different areas
yeah I could see that yeah like you
could you know you sneeze come or I feel
like you might be able to spit it I feel
like some point you could shake up and
spit into somebody oh I like the
genitalia might change yeah yeah I'm
curious to see what could change in the
future yeah but yeah I think so I think
I think I think female genitalia will
stay the same
yeah you know sometimes you have you you
need to have a skill and you don't have
time to go to college dude how long does
it take to go to college four years and
you probably have to knock a chick up oh
that's hectic now there's something
called Skillshare it's basically a place
it's a learning platform actually it's
not a place and it has over 20,000
classes in business social media design
technology marketing you can take all
those classes right there on Skillshare
so whether you're trying to you know get
deeper into your already
you know already you know real crevasse
II skill set or rather you're just
trying to learn something new skill
share has it think about something you
can't do right now and suddenly you can
and that's what skill share does for you
so join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our tpw listeners
get two months of skill share for just
99 cents
that's right skill share is offering tpw
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 20,000 classes for just 99 cents
go to Skillshare comm slash Theo von and
that is Skillshare comm slash Theo von
this Louie thing man it's it's got in
your head huh well yeah it's just
interesting I'm just like and then I'm
like you know it's um and then a lot of
people would say yeah it's like people
would be afraid to say anything about
Apatow cuz people would be worried about
their space in the industry you know
well yeah but that but I said my two
cents on John I like judge I said we're
cool John and I are cool be a judge
always anytime where him and I talked
about doing a podcast you know him
coming on the podcast and stuff so yeah
he goes on a lot of people's podcast I
like Judd yeah I said that before I'm
not I didn't slander of Judd I don't
know why Judd or anybody wants to take
shots at Lois that's my point
right I'm not taking shots at Judd I
don't [ __ ] I'm not on that right I'm
saying I don't know why people feel like
they need to woody but also do you feel
like you feel like we need to there's
something oh I agree it's unless you've
got like you said if Judd and Louie have
some old beef well then maybe that makes
more sense
but there's comics there's a few comics
that I have heavy heavy beef with that I
do not like as people yeah but let me
tell you something if they go down in a
blaze of fire I am gonna say [ __ ] I
might say to you as my friend
right off the record when I'm not about
to tweet about him but what about dice
like dice is another guy that's gone on
but dice keeps going after people I
don't know why he's doing that you think
it's just part of I feel like for dice
everything as part of his schtick here's
what I think it is it isn't me being
honest I think dice is older he's of the
older generation yeah and this kind of
what's going on is upsetting to him a
little bit because he's not in it in it
anymore
yeah he probably
would [ __ ] hate me here and name me
saying that but that's the fact yeah
like dice ain't on that Forbes list well
he's dressed like a damn mechanic at him
from Mad Max don't you [ __ ] see the
dude [ __ ] he's still [ __ ] dressed like
that one homeless dude at the gym it's
like if you're if sayin if you're gonna
like he's that guy has never been
friendly to around me he brought me on
that page one time and was it he was an
[ __ ] about it never met him one I'd
just got the vibe from him that he he
only cares solely about himself yeah
look at him dude that's insane someone's
like if your grandfather went in the
attic and found a box of stuff he used
to wear when he was young he's like I'm
putting this on yeah yeah now I'll say
this he I thought he did a good job in a
star is born
he played what's I didn't see that [ __ ]
not leaning what's the other girl's name
stars born is is Bradley Cooper and Lady
Gaga Lady Gaga's dad he played Lady
Gaga's daddy no no he thought he did a
good job he was in Blue Ivy too right
wasn't who I he was good as [ __ ] that
so yeah I mean he's definitely yeah
there he wait that's him right there
yeah yeah yeah it doesn't look like him
but that is him yeah but look going
because he doesn't have his a chain
wallet on right I thought yeah he looks
like a like a skateboard so like a
skateboarder they like I thought you're
gonna say he looks like a skateboard
yeah a skateboard too many stickers he
looks like the back he looks like the
back of like a like a bumper in high
school that's it looks like he just has
all these accoutrements on him it's
flare yeah bro you got too much flare
bro he looks like he works at a Chili's
in [ __ ] Hell's Kitchen
you know that's a or in hell maybe does
it there was a bike you works at a
Chili's at a Slayer concert what is that
bar with all this [ __ ] on the walls you
don't talking about they make fun of it
in shenanigans shenanigans yeah yeah
yeah it's easily he's like a walking
shenanigans yeah too many trinkets to
money 13x yeah too much nickname there
that's yeah is that is that dice or what
is that oh that's a bumper Oh somebody
in a Berkeley so anyone here's the thing
about dice I don't know he keeps going
to know people he wouldn't Sebastian
yeah that was [ __ ] up that was so
[ __ ] up because I love Sebastian so I
don't think Sebastian has one [ __ ]
enemy in the game I don't think he's
done anyone wrong as far as
I [ __ ] know someone might have some
dirt but he went after Sebastian for no
[ __ ] reason yeah he said something
like he stole he stole his Stiles
yeah essence it's not that he stole
jokes right by the way the one rule of
comics that we all know you don't steal
material other than that if someone says
you're like me bro everybody's like
somebody yeah everyone is going to feel
a little bit like somebody from a prior
generation right at some pie no one's
new what the [ __ ] are we talking about
right you go back to the beginning of
stand-up itself or vaudevillian
performances that's where we take all of
our comedic mannerisms from anyway yeah
you'd be a liar to say that you're
completely original is [ __ ] well in
there there almost is no originality in
some ways that may happen you can have
your own experience of something but
most people we've all shared like you
know things that have happened in the
world and I remember even like whenever
I first started doing comedy
everybody was sounding like Mitch
Hedberg everybody everybody that's so
funny everyone's trying to be a
one-liner comedian usually yeah some
agents said to me one time he's like you
sound like Mitch Hedberg you know you
did [ __ ] yeah somebody said but it was
just everybody was ya know but I don't
think you I don't ever ever have seen
you be that way but I just think it was
just one of them I mean this was right
in the beginning but it was like some
people it's just that's how you learn to
tell a joke you heard it told that way
dude somebody that you loved yeah I
remember the first couple of jokes I
wrote I sounded like it to myself
looking back I sounded like Swardson oh
wow
cuz I love dick dude I mean I still love
him I'm saying I remember I've said this
before I'm he's that rare baby bird bro
I had his half-hour Comedy Central
special I have it VHS I love cuz I love
brother [ __ ] the most genius I
remember writing jokes sounding like his
cadence oh yeah cuz I was like I love
the way he does it
but you're always gonna sound like
somebody but for dice to say Sebastian
stole his act or whatever is crazy if
you listen to them side by side they're
nothing alike
yeah I think just because they both seem
like they it's a you know wait for a
subway you know they both look like
dudes that are at the bus yeah yeah at
the bus do is it are angry at the bus
stop about something man and they might
drive the bus the bus might show up and
they might have to drive it okay and the
bus the Sebastian by the way the reason
that [ __ ] dice hates that is because
Sebastian is an extremely success
yeah clean is the wrong word but
well-formatted put together artists
artists and dice was more raw and dirty
and Sebastian isn't like that right
they're kind of like the antithesis of
each hundred percent just cuz they both
have an accent I mean that's like that's
that's like saying yeah you know that's
like saying that you you you sound like
you sound like every southern comedian
who has a draw draw a little bit yeah
that's crazy so have another commune was
like Theo von stole my [ __ ] yeah I am
the southern comedian that's four that's
[ __ ] insane and your money that's the
inside of mud there's dead muscle in the
middle of my tongue cuz confirm that
sound a lot of the way that I do
what do you why do you think it's dead
hmm I don't know just I just years of
stress do you think it's just the Lord I
mean I would guess I wouldn't do that
nobody else would do it you you talk
about you talk about the Lord do you
ever go to church
yeah you do how often you go I go
probably I would say eight times a year
eight times it's okay that's pretty good
it's not bad these days yeah most people
don't go at all yeah but but you're not
you know what are you Lutheran what
would you do dude I would say I'm
probably Baptist you know yeah somewhere
in the mix of white and black Baptist do
you sing I'll sing a little yeah yeah
you'll get it I bet you I get I bet you
get way more to the sing and then you
would like to lately don't I sing I sing
standing up and I will put my hands up I
put my hands up - yeah yeah cuz you feel
that you have I mean it's kind of weird
to see someone singing that's not into
it yeah you either got to not sing or go
or go for it oh there's always that
there's a whole family that sits down
and sings at our church at home
sometimes and they sit sit and sing yes
that's [ __ ] alarming yeah that's a
little weird that's not cereal rush yeah
yeah he's dying Jesus I know somebody's
now I start bleeding but what but then
so bad what's his name he also called I
he brought up Ari recently which was
kind of crazy dice Brothers she took
shots at Ari yeah so far are you alright
Ari's probably the one do not take shots
at especially will it take sad Ari
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah our dude Howard
Stern went toe to toe with Ari you know
funny business
the king of media and radio Ari was like
the first one to be like [ __ ] you he
doesn't give a [ __ ] of all people he'll
take shots at anybody who takes shots at
him
he never starts wars but man he'll
[ __ ] hilt he would love he loves to
fight
yeah he's the first guy to be like okay
you want to talk [ __ ] cuz Ari doesn't
have anything to lose
he's like that he has that same vibe oh
speaking of which I saw this online you
got to look this up Doug Stanhope voiced
his opinion about did you see this about
about Louie he did now that I want to
stay on the [ __ ] Louie [ __ ]
but Doug came for cuz Doug is a guy that
says [ __ ] you to everybody yeah [ __ ] the
industry you know the funniest thing I
think he ever said he was in the
greenroom talkin [ __ ] to somebody and
Eric Griffin walked in and we did that
Showtime show together that I'm dying up
here show hmm and he says uh Doug
Stanhope says significant oh we were
just talking [ __ ] about you
hey Griffin what were you saying and he
goes we're talking about that terrible
[ __ ] piece-of-shit show that you're
on and Griff started laughing and he
told me that I started laughing - he's
eight right to his face he goes that
show sucks it's [ __ ] terrible but I
was like good at least he's honest I'd
rather that then when comics lied to you
about [ __ ] yeah dude I love I love the
thing that you I'd rather you not say
anything to me or if you're a real
friend and he's not even it wasn't a
friend of Eric he was just like that
shit's garbage yeah but they had to
laugh about it but I Wow thank God he
knew somebody was truthful you know but
I think about this sometimes like it's
so hard see looking at people let's read
what he said real quick take Louie CK
out of the equation that's exactly what
we were just saying they're mad at him
not at the thing if a full performance
of Hamilton was pirated and uploaded the
internet how would it be legal for all
those [ __ ] gossip websites to be up
to provide that illegally obtained
content on their sites correctly correct
it's a great point it's only because
yeah that and that's one thing sometimes
about the about some of these liberal
sites it's like the rules only apply if
they apply the way that they want them
to well that to me is my biggest problem
with like you know I'm not I'm not a
lefty and I'm not a righty I don't like
either I think both people are insane
but I do think the biggest problem I
have living in a leftist place like
California lefties can get mad unless it
applies to them right and then they go
well no no no but but no but for this no
yeah but it's like what you jus just you
just threw stones at all that [ __ ]
before
dude armor being in school and
statistics or something and it was like
it was freshman year in college and the
teachers like Stu
typically speaking it was 1400 kids in
the class who like to eat you guys'll
die in car accidents one of you guys be
a registered sex offender
she was right wasn't she no I remember
standing up and going not it not it
that's good no get the [ __ ] outta me
okay I mean uh I can't I mean I just let
the Lord know what I didn't want she
they put out so many false statistics to
us when we were kids I feel like can we
r of wearing this Emily I'd say you look
blind if you could jerk off in the man
you go blind crush your eyes too long
ago blind I remember I remember the
worst one was this is something I've
talked about before everybody this is
what this was in school and sex ed class
everybody is gonna get herpes I remember
them saying that they were like one out
of four one out of four yeah let me tell
you I know four people and I don't think
they have herpes I don't know why they
think everyone is you know they used to
tell you we're gonna get HIV you people
they know everybody HIV we're gonna
harass ya you were gonna get AIDS sued
they tried to stop football at our
school because of HIV
there were some kid habit in case of
blood yeah that's correct that is crazy
[ __ ] you would have to had a
conversation about this to someone was
like well you know it's easier to get
than you think I was like no bro it's
harder to get then you [ __ ] through
you have to really you have to yeah you
have to beat yourself up and then [ __ ]
somebody when you've definitely been on
just gotten out of a fire almost right
and then you might not get AIDS yeah
here's the best way that I look at it
Magic Johnson's wife doesn't have AIDS
yeah Wow and he's the all-time leader in
assists you think he didn't get you
think he didn't try to [ __ ] oh I
don't get come my buddy Jim's uncle he
always says he's always that cuz he's
gay because made you Chancellor mr.
homosexual yeah I was like you think so
he goes oh yeah his wife would have it
by now yep and I said and I said my
buddy Jim's uncle he said he said you're
being crazy he's like he wasn't gay and
he goes he goes oh yeah you don't know
any other straight guys with AIDS
nobody had any answers it's true yeah
it's a good point and they call them
bobcats in a black community a gay man I
call him Bob Bob that's why I don't let
him creepin yeah probably cuz they sexy
but they still doing something they said
you know kill you yeah but they called
gay men in the
in the black community Bobcats my
favorite joke that you tell by the way
when we get on stage at the Comedy Store
you always do this to Jeff you do this
to me too
yeah almost has the same thing to me
every time I come on you said that
somebody steps on ya which is so funny
you know why cuz that's true
Miami with another child yeah yeah wow I
didn't know that I can step that you
said that step you have a step son anger
in you always violent it's a red that's
true and all redheads or stepsons all
redheads exceptions have to be because
the original father was never gonna
stick around yeah
once they see the red hair my god into
drugs and like what is this is something
out of the garden put it back put it
back yeah but you you always say that
give it up for that someone stepson
Santino and then he says Jeff who plays
the piano you always say he's you know
he's blind
you always said about Jeff and I love
every single some one time I was I can
give it up for Jeff he's terminally ill
and everybody laughed it's pretty
interesting when do you know that you
had red hair was there time you realized
it in your life that you realized that
you were redheaded person and yeah yeah
probably probably when I was probably
when I was kindergarten in kindergarten
I got no that's where sluggard that
slugger Santino [ __ ] came from I
told that story cuz I would get into
fights and the teacher I got kicked out
of Moody Bible I got kicked out of a
Catholic school cuz fighting I got
kicked out of another kid I kicked out
of two different places for fighting Wow
that's when I knew because people would
make fun of my hair so I got defensive
my first move was always to punch
somebody yeah that was the first thing I
wanted to do you had violence in you Oh
constantly but it was only because you
look so religious do people tell you
that a lot I look you know what be very
Catholic helpful people would say so
Catholic likes like church people look
like you could ask them for favors or
ask them for directions and you have
that youth pastor beard going people
always can come people come up to me
they go tell me tell me what the day is
gonna bring ya ask me for directions
than you can ever imagine really because
red-headed people don't look they look
well if someone's lost in LA and they
see a room of you guys we're all
standing on the corner they would ask me
first because they think you know well
he is a he's involved he's involved he
might be the he might be either the
leader or the wolf yeah
you guys could just be guys right I have
to film it'll see us mm-hmm
no I stand out and they go I wonder if
he's a leader or if he's a wolf or or if
he's he's the devil himself when you
want to say hi to the devil if you saw
him in the corner
oh yeah you go talk to him for a minute
oh yeah they say asked me how do you get
to Sawtelle oh yeah and I always always
always always lie yeah like I've ever
given a real direction of my life I
never people say hey how do you get to
Hollywood in Highland yeah I go down La
Brea as far as I've never given a real
direction yeah I think that's my
favorite thing to do in LA what I
realize about one thing I realized about
directions is that um is that like the
second I ask somebody form right when
they start giving them to me I don't
[ __ ] want to know many more I just
want to go figure it out myself look at
my phone yeah like I I can't I can't
anymore they take too long to tell you
too long you know what bothers me is
when someone's this but this happening
yesterday when someone is too chatty in
line for a thing I'm trying to get a
coffee or yeah and this woman was
chatting with a girl at the front and
I'm not a nice guy when I'm impatient
and hungry and I get real angry and she
was chatting and I kept going like this
yeah like that making sounds like that
and she turn around and she goes oh I'm
so sorry and I said you know I didn't
say anything I know it's my way of
saying you gotta just go yeah people get
too chatty
I don't you can't be chatty with
strangers you know like take it do the
thing hey there how you doing today uh
but then you got to keep going
I don't like chatty people yeah I don't
like to sit when someone wants to engage
with me like airplanes or anywhere
you're stuck with somebody yeah I I
don't chat dude I don't want to chat
with you man I'm not a chatty guy one
lady I remember one time I had pretty
bad body gas on a flight right you were
but you were were you letting it out
slow brother was nothing I could do it
was almost like something it just I
don't know like a ghost was in me and
didn't want to come out all at once and
there was a lady next to me and I kept
blaming her on a baby you know cuz I had
a baby nearby [ __ ] baby oh yeah and
it's a girl - first I thought it was a
boy that it was a girl baby and I felt
so bad you know there is something
[ __ ] up about blaming that on
baby yeah it's kinda yeah that's mean
but then at one point the lady was
really buying into that it was this baby
creating this sense I kept looking at
the baby yeah in the blue he was getting
soap it the lady next be getting so
pissed at this [ __ ] baby and then one
time brother was once she goes oh that
one was warm I was like god I got to get
some help for myself sometimes when I
have to fart on airplanes I'll get up
and on the way to the bathroom I'll fart
through the aisle one of my favorite
things to do I don't like any of those
people on the plane anyway I feel like
every time you get on any airplane make
they call that go into Jersey if you
fart down the middle of the Turnpike I
take the Turnpike all the way to the
bathroom I like to fart go to the
bathroom wash my hands and then wait
about a minute and then when I come out
you know people in the aisles are doing
this yeah yeah and I walk by and I go oh
and they then they then they think I
think it's them and then they go I guess
yeah no big gross do by the way I almost
died coming back into LA on a flight
really may be the scariest fight I've
ever had I've heard I've heard a lot of
comments talk about bad scary coming
back to town flights when you're on the
road dude I've learned so many times
this was so [ __ ] bad when we landed
finally they said that they had to
ground airplanes from leaving because
the wind was so strong in Burbank and it
was so strong coming out of Vegas I'm
not even remotely kidding we had we came
in like this the whole time very
dangerous Vegas Oh bro the worst and it
was about 100 200 feet above the ground
like that's how that's how much gap we
had left and instead of trying to glide
like that dude went nose-down I mean do
we mean we bounced when we hit that's
how hard we hit and everyone's holding
on and then when I got off the plane
there was a priest waiting at the
terminal hmm and I went up to him I gave
him a big hug
uh-uh I said thanks man thanks for
everything they knew he knew dude I said
I got he said III understand my son and
then and that's why we do when you're on
those planes what would you do it's
going down what do you do what do they
always play the same logger
I play this game with a friend what are
your last two words
you're gonna crash like it's whoa
barreling down towards the ground and
the pilots act this is it this is a we
can't we're gonna [ __ ] around two
words that's all you have what do you
say [ __ ] man and so you ate a lot of
meal out of the [ __ ] that's good man
that's really good but I would my work
my words would be knew it knew it just
to get with it it's just a [ __ ] with
everyone's head on the plane right it is
wrong now we go do it just a [ __ ]
everyone's but why do you tell us I love
that idea
no but you know what you know what I
think about all the time huh and I was
with my [ __ ] wife on this flight but
it was getting so bumpy there was a
really attractive girl sitting across
the aisle and I thought I think I would
kiss my wife first but then I would also
go kiss that hot girl cuz I just I
thought about that I thought if we die
I'm gonna get one on my wife and I gotta
get one on this strange night she's it's
that'll be it I'll never have this again
dude I would I think probably stand up
in front of everybody maybe stand on my
seat and just open my ass up to
everybody just one more time yeah they
have them be like what the [ __ ] and then
they just died right before they died
yeah the last thing they see is your
[ __ ] and but you don't see anything
you just you feel like yeah I just feel
a little joy yeah they're gonna tear
that would be something they'd be pretty
awesome and I would love citing what I
what I love to see is when I'm on a
really bad bad flight I love to see
somebody not bothered I think that's the
most gangster [ __ ] I seen a guy reading
a newspaper we were in a we're in a
[ __ ] storm whipping us around the
Duke and the dude was going like this
annoyed that the fact he couldn't in the
newspaper wouldn't stand still everybody
else is doing this thing on the seat and
he was like pissed off like angry at the
air some people are so yeah usually
that's like a rich guy like real real
guys they don't die like if they die
they just come back back at their house
yeah they will figure they are back at
their house the next day yeah they just
wake up in they're alive again yeah yeah
rich people don't die yeah they don't
die do you know who passed away today
I wait here I know who mean Jean Oakland
well he died last night he did he
this morning was Bob Einstein you knew
that is Bob Einstein you guys know who
that is my son's bagels he all night
signs but no Super Dave from Curb Your
Enthusiasm you're a super day Marty
funkhauser Wow
yeah he passed away it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] made me so mad that dude was so
cool he his brothers Albert Brooks you
guys know what you know album Brooks
yeah that's his brother he's dope dude
and he died and yeah Mean Gene died last
night and very sad that means you and I
yeah that love you know you know him
Marty funkhauser from curb he [ __ ]
down him when do you think he died man
what do I think I died yeah honestly I
think I live longer than I'm supposed to
wow I just had a vision you don't and
I'm not even joking bro and I mean that
in a bad way I love you and everything
but I just what am I gonna go
37 bro that's in like a year and a half
sorry man yeah that's crazy
alright I guess open you were already 37
then I was gonna be like how do I go huh
how do I go it's a surprise man I know
how you go you do mm-hmm
you gonna be a hundred and sixteen
you'll be the oldest living person in
the United States of America because it
can't be worldwide there's always some
old dude in India who's like 190 and
it's a woman yeah but you are flying
back to Louisiana
mm and they're gonna give you an award
for the oldest person the United States
like a paper award then bro it's a it's
a it's a huge plaque like a huge plaque
and the plane lands and you get off the
plane and everyone is cheering loudly
you are getting so much praise and love
then the news is there you know everyone
so happy and as you're walking down the
steps to get out Jim you get
assassinated assassinated at a hundred
and sixteen mm-hmm mm-hmm why you did
some [ __ ] in your 70s damn you did some
fucked-up [ __ ] in your 70s would you
kill yourself in the dude that kills you
by the way black I know Brandon showers
Brandon showers his nephew Brandon
showers is nephew hmm
does he have brain issues from fighting
mm-hmm [ __ ] everybody does you know when
one member of your family fights
everybody gets brain damage when I kill
myself what would you say when I kill
myself my what would you kill yourself
you think if if if you could you think I
can but I won't
I would never yeah I wouldn't either I
would never in a million years
you know I've joked about I joke I joke
about suicide and my lady doesn't like
it but I tell her because I joke about I
would never do it right I've had three
friends killed himself three four mmm
and the big most annoying thing in the
world is when someone goes did you see
it coming like no [ __ ] we would
have stopped it yeah doesn't make any
goddamn sense yeah we wouldn't have let
Lance [ __ ] jump off of a [ __ ]
building if he told us if he sent a
couple of emails behind yo thinking
about jumping off a building did you see
it coming yeah we would have [ __ ]
stopped it if you talkable
no I think because you joke about
suicide because I joke about [ __ ] like
that because comedy you have to just
pick apart sadness mmm I think I would
never you know how they say you know
they say suicide is selfish they say
it's a most selfish act yeah I think
it's the opposite I think it's
completely selfless
I think selfish people would never kill
themselves because they because they
want to live oh that's interesting so
much people want to live I'm a selfish
person I'm gonna live I want to see how
this turns out yeah I don't want to kill
my [ __ ] so that's insane why what a
waste that sucks I think I think
selflessness causes people to cuz they
just don't want to be anymore they don't
make anything of themselves for they
yeah yeah they're just like I don't like
I don't like me and I don't want to
burden other people people say selfish
because they're like you don't know what
you've left in your wake it's like I
don't know I mean they come they do but
they just don't want to be in it they
just want to do the thing anymore
yeah I couldn't I would never you would
never I wouldn't kill myself dude never
not as an adult man I would have done it
when I was a child or something I used
to think about it yeah I just get real
sad hard being a teenager dude your arms
like grow overnight in [ __ ] your arms
are longer than all your body yeah my
and my hands are said to hit the ground
when I walked dude yeah one of my
buddies came to school his [ __ ] neck
was like a foot and a half long
one week yeah like what the [ __ ] but in
a year he grows out of it yeah it don't
match at all that time where you're like
the pieces are all [ __ ] up dude how
can you not but yeah ya know as a
teenager I thought about it sometime I
used to do this some sad [ __ ] Pearl Jam
has a song called better man oh yeah
when I got mad I would go sing and cry
and my room to that file I saw when I
was like I want to kill myself did I
used to cry at the gym listen to O'Town
that will make you cry yeah but why
would you at the gym because it would
hit you hard yeah cuz I was that kind of
still kind of a showman even though I
was [ __ ] said you like to be out in
public yeah you public cry I have what
does last time you cried as an adult Oh
probably last week or something I mean
you know listen our podcast obviously no
[ __ ] but I mean a real for real oh
yeah then bro hard oh not like that
emotional bro I get him okay I'm talking
about cry for real like I get emotional
I like Cheerios commercials oh yeah I
cried oh I cried about probably a week
and a half ago I was listening to a sad
country song it got you yeah I put it on
just so it gets me I do that too I put
on sad [ __ ] when I get sad and I'm angry
I take a drive I put on even sadder [ __ ]
yeah yeah so I really get it oh dude
I'll [ __ ] get so [ __ ] sad oh yeah
like you know what I do sometimes if I'm
getting real sad and I put on the
saddest [ __ ] music I can find and I
go by the old house I used to live in at
the Culver City and just sit out front
and cry like a [ __ ] oh dude I'll Drive
a lady that lives there now has seen me
a few times
oh really yeah oh dude I think she just
watches I think she just likes it she'll
stand there and watch me cry in the car
oh that ain't that sad dude I'll
sometimes bro I'll go to the [ __ ]
graveyard and write my brother's name on
half of the graves with a permanent
marker huh the perimeter Mart with a
sharpie no no not a pen a pen doesn't
work but you can use a marker yeah yeah
sharpie marker a sharpie yeah and it
wash it doesn't wash off though I don't
stay that long you never stay long
enough to [ __ ] lose my [ __ ] get out
of there and sometimes I'll stand and
I'll get there's even like with this one
graveyard weather the grass is like a
hole on the ground I'll even crouch down
in there and sit for a while yeah like
I'm dead to daytime though yeah you
won't do nighttime no you can't be
anywhere near there do you hold your
breath that's outside I like to get yeah
you ever hold your breath when you go
past a graveyard
do you know that no do you never play
that game when you were kids and the
kind of game dude it's a game no it's
lift your feet up when you go past a
graveyard
no it's hold your breath really yeah
hold your breath because you don't to
suck in the souls of the Dead really
yeah but meanwhile you're sitting in the
graveyard sucking on every [ __ ] soul
you can
how about this you know people go watch
movies at the cemetery have you ever
done that in that light you don't know
about this
oh dude I'll listen I'll play that movie
Nicolas Cage was in angels what's that
movie called angels in the outfield yeah
I'll play angels in the outfield do the
soundtrack that's a baseball movie is it
yeah well it still has angels in it and
I'll play angels in the outfield and
[ __ ] right my brother's name on all
the graves at a graveyard every single
grave no six or seven yeah that's all
set yeah not too sad if it was like 50
or 60 then to be weird sad oh I'll get
sad bro you can't get sadder than that
know when you get sad at your house
where do you go anywhere man shower oh I
used to do that in my 20s I would cry in
the shower I couldn't I never did that
really I think it's a cry in front of a
mirror now so I can see I can look at it
you want to know what's really going I
like to feel at all I can't do anything
in the shower but shower I don't like
[ __ ] I don't jerk off you know people
used to drug off in the shower I think
that's weird yeah it's just a con
comfortable I like to be dry when I jerk
off for some reason
oh yeah I could see that like I don't
like pool pool [ __ ] I did a Middle
Eastern of you yeah yeah we'd like to be
driving for ajan just jerking off into
the dry abyss all the time in the desert
Oh jerk I've jerked off in the desert
yeah when I lived in Arizona I used to
sit outside nice to hold a cactus with
one hand and just jerk off with the
other one I like the pain yeah like a
dry pain that's say it yeah that's real
sad yeah I think you win are you on the
road anytime soon
throw your date's out there man I go
Bakersfield January 19th I've never done
that before
we're at the Brewing Co yeah dude is it
fun is it fun
it'll be great man it's awesome yeah
I've heard a bunch of people have done
it I know Diaz did it a bunch of people
have done it and they asked to come do
it so I'll Bakersfield January 19th and
then the next weekend I'll be at the
draft house in Arlington which is like
DC so if you're in the DC area January
24 25 26 the rest of the dates I'm
lining up but you know go to the website
go to Andrew Santino calm and see all
that [ __ ] yeah man well thank you for
coming on bro thank you about to get
over there to whiskey ginger some time
got to come you have to you have to come
over and also we have to figure out this
whole this thing because this is this is
not they can't cut this in half well I
just wonder what the [ __ ] deal is I
texted Brandon Brennan Bret Brennan he
said left doughnut took you door
that's cute you know it's really funny
you know you know he never fought you
know that was a lie he has a twin
did he really yeah that wasn't him oh
wow
yeah it was [ __ ] he is it twin yeah
identical twin Jesus shut it down ro he
used to fight not not Brent Brent burber
Island shop he never fought
oh dude Burton yeah Burton shot birthday
Burton cheap Burton shaved the [ __ ]
Burton cheap Jewish prizefighter yeah
really yeah you know he went to he went
to a doctor to get the ear thing the
cauliflower ear uh-huh that was
manufactured no way fake fake fake fake
that's fake they can do that now mm-hmm
we're in America no you got to go
overseas yeah yeah you gotta go overseas
my god his ears done just so he could be
like that was me leave that no but his
brother was a real Mon the Delta
fighting whoo Bryson cowers recent
showers is that his name yeah he lives
in Canada Oh way up north and that's his
this is his twin Jesus huh that that and
that that to me is why he's playing this
hole you tied game yeah I don't know
what their deal is man I mean I'm gonna
call him after this and find out but um
let's go find definitely but I'll say
this you definitely you know if you even
came in third did he say you came in
third I came in third wow that's huge
bro thank you you weren't even in it
wasn't even close wasn't even a sniff
wasn't even around came came through
well we made some noise I think this
this people people wanted this to happen
people wanted us to sit down yeah and
we'll do it again I've had a piece so
bad during this man it's been hard for
me to [ __ ] thing let's go pee Andrew
slugger Santino thanks for coming in man
yeah good to see you bro what does it
again soon yeah yeah cheers bro
[Music]
I'm fooling like these leaves I must be
I'll share this piece of thought it's
gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake can let myself all my
[Music]